le laboratoire de santé publique du
québec est le fer de lance de cette
recherche dans la province il est situé
à sainte anne de bellevue et c'est là
que se font vous envoyer des images
c'est là que se font tous les tests de
détection du comique 19 dans la province
soit plus de 200 je pensais 250 depuis
le début de l'épidémie la
microbiologiste a fait que c'est
l'adjectif phare fait partie de la
douzaine de personnes qui y travaillent
un autre affaire bonjour bonsoir en soi
alors est-ce que ce laboratoire on
parlait de contingence tout à l'heure ce
laboratoire qui est essentielle en ce
moment de la détection de dépistage des
maladies de sa propagation
est-ce qu' un plan de contingence à
votre laboratoire
oui un plan de contingence en fait que
différentes choses qu'on fait au niveau
de l'équipe de direction
on vérifie qui peut remplacer qui je
vous donne un exemple moi je
microbiologiste-infectiologue qu'on ait
deux microbiologiste-infectiologue à
l'intérieur du laboratoire donc on peut
se remplacer puis au niveau des
différentes opérations du laboratoire
qui a il ya différentes personnes qui
peuvent faire les tâches d'une personne
qui tomberait malade on a recensé aussi
parmi l'équipe de technologiste médicale
quelles sont les compétences des
différentes technologies ce parce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est que le laboratoire
est séparée en plusieurs secteurs
oui on fait de la parasitologie ont fait
de mycologie on a juste dû covin
synergie du coït 19
donc on est en train de recenser les
compétences des différentes technologies
pour savoir qui pourrait remplacer une
technologie qui tomberaient malades dans
un secteur donné
puis on est aussi établi une liste des
analyses à prioriser à maintenir à tout
prix parce que ce qu'il faut comprendre
c'est que certaines analyses qu'on fait
qui pourrait potentiellement prendre du
retard on pourrait se permettre que ça
prenne du retard 5 c'est nécessairement
un impact clinique au niveau du patient
donc ces analyses le vent est délesté en
premier pour faire la place alors on
voit que tout le monde se préparer au
premier chef de laboratoire donc il des
pistes le qu'ovide 19
quoi qu'il en soit quoi qu'il advienne
de votre laboratoire ça quand vous
travaillez aussi outre de dépister les
cas c'est
faire en sorte que dorénavant les
hôpitaux puissent faire ce test de
dépistage eux mais n'est ce pas oui ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est que nos
professionnels au laboratoire de santé
publique ont développé un test sur un
appareil qui s'appelle un point studios
ces techniques un peu mais ce qu'on
essaie de faire en ce moment comme en
collaboration avec des partenaires dans
des hôpitaux
c'est d'adapter notre recette de test
pour qu'ils et elles soient utilisables
sur des appareils qui sont répandus dans
les centres hospitaliers alors c'était
ce en ce moment le test pour détecter le
cockpit d'un 10e je me lève d'un
prélèvement de salive quelque chose
comme ça c'est un échantillon sanguin ou
c'est ça peut être différent
échantillons c'est surtout une essence
championne naso pharyngé donc un petit
con qu'on fait tourner les tailleurs
dîner et un prélèvement de gorge
oui mais on peut aussi faire
l'analyse sur lavage broncho alvéolaire
donc un pneumologue qui va chercher
professional pour mon prochain
un crachin bon tout ça s'est mis sur des
plaquettes les gens ont peut-être déjà
le seuil c'est c'est l'appareil qui
analyse cette plaque est qu'ils voient
ce qu'il ya dedans kiki kia dans les
hôpitaux ou qui ferait peut-être pas
compatible avec avec le test ou quoi
c'est qu'il ya différentes machines qui
peuvent faire de l'amplification et de
la détection d'acides nucléiques donc
nous on utilise une machine donné que sa
façon de détecter l'acide nucléique et
il faut qu'on adapte dans le fond notre
notre recette pour que les appareils qui
sont disponibles dans le réseau puisse
faire le même travail
bon en ce moment entre l'arrivée de
l'échantillon laboratoire et le résultat
ça prend combien de temps là où vous
êtes le plus long que ça peut prendre
ces 24 heures dans un timing parfait
nous les champions arrive si on est tous
prêts à travailler ça peut prendre 5 avr
alors si vous parvenez à trouver la
compatibilité entre votre recette les
appareils des hôpitaux
ça prendrait donc 5 heures je présume en
un moment où le patient ordre l'hôpital
et le dépistage le résultat du test dans
un moment idéal mais il faut comprendre
que les hôpitaux vont pas nécessairement
partir
le test à toutes les aires donc ça
pourrait quand même être un petit peu
plus long alors ce serait forcément de
toute façon plus rapide dans un hôpital
parce qu'ils auraient pas le transfert
de l'échantillon et cetera puis qu'on
aurait résultat tout aussi rapidement
quand même
maintenant si vous parvenez à trouver
cette compatibilité hla ce que vous
travaillez avec les quatre hôpitaux
désignés par québec où elle aussi tous
les hôpitaux du québec dispose de cette
espèce de machine qui pourrait lire
l'échantillon il ya peu plus que les
quatre hôpitaux mais ça c'est vraiment
le ministère qui va décider en fonction
des demandes des volume d'échantillons
où est ce qu'on va distribuer le test
d'accord et si donc vous le faites à ce
que ces même envisageable que ce test là
votre recette comme vous it soit
partager avec les autres provinces ou
d'autres pays déjà la communauté
scientifique se parle on a des réunions
hebdomadaires est plus qu'une réunion
hebdomadaire avec nos homologues des
autres laboratoires de santé publics
provinciaux les gens partagent leur
amour se partagent leurs recettes le
protocole qui a été mise au point par u2
charest est inspirée en partie par un
protocole allemand pourquoi une un
exemple donc les gens collaborent
l'information circule donc oui les bons
coups qui qui serait fait ici vont être
partagés on n'est pas dans les brevets
l'on n'est pas là dedans on est on est
dans la priorité santé publique
et est ce que vous vous redoutez
une propagation avez vous l'impression
que vous à votre laboratoire si si vous
ne trouvez pas rapidement la le partage
de votre set avec les hôpitaux d'être
débordé éventuellement par les quatre
dépistage c'est sûr qu'on regarde ce qui
se passe à travers le monde puis tout le
monde cette crainte là qu'on se retrouve
un petit peu comment en 2009 quand on a
eu la grippe porcine h1n1 qui est
devenue une pandémie
donc on redoutent le scénario de
pandémie puis oui on travaille fort on
se prépare pour être et si ce scénario
là et vous pensez pouvoir donc trouvé
cette compatibilité en votre set et les
appareils des hôpitaux d'ici combien de
temps ça devrait prendre quelques
semaines on est quand même confiant
qu'on va réussir à avancer compatibilité
merci beaucoup docteur faveur synthétise
pas